Jordan Peterson was on Piers Morgan's
show in the UK this is from about eight
or ten days ago and Piers asked him how
does this War end
how does this war end do you think
we're going to find out this winter well
I I know what I would do in his shoes
I'd wait till the first cold snap and
shut off the tops right because I was
going to do this got the control over
there
of course he's going to do that he's
already warned the West with his
insistence that maintenance problems
were necessary and the pipelines do you
think he will use a nuclear weapon
if necessary he'll use a tactical
Battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't probably why
because we wouldn't respond
what's in it for us
if you let him do it and get away with
it where does that end then you are into
it well there's a lot you can get
yourself in this situation no problem
where there's no good outcome we're
trying to do that right now on every
front we can possibly imagine we can
easily get ourselves in a situation
where it's hell this way and hell that
way that we're that's highly probable
the reason I wanted to show you that
clip I mean you guys know my feelings
about Jordan but it's so interesting how
there's so little honest political
analysis about what's going on in Russia
Ukraine in essence if you say anything
like ah I don't really want World War
III I am a little bit concerned that
we're poking the bear with this guy it
doesn't mean that what he did was right
or that Crimea should be taken back to
Russia or any of that stuff they
basically call you a Russian operative
this is exactly what Hillary Clinton did
to Tulsi gabbard when she wasn't taking
the the Democrat Party Line on Russia
from two years ago and on Syria Etc this
is what they do so there's very little
Divergence from mainstream opinion on
this which is that we should just keep
escalating I for one would prefer not to
be involved in World War III I've had a
nice run the last couple years things
are feeling good uh could we maybe not
do the dropping nukes all over the place
uh but Jordan calmly because he's not
Jordan's not a political analyst he's
not purely a political analyst what he's
talking about is human in Psychology the
human psychology that is driving Putin
that is driving all these International
actors some to escalate some to not
understand what they're escalating for
given more more weapons more weapons
keep defeating him that seems right but
you have to understand human psychology
of what happens to people when they're
on the verge of losing what happens to
that wounded dog in the corner in those
last moments you think it might lash out
so Jordan continued to lay out some of
the outcomes that could happen to all of
us if we keep escalating this thing
everybody I met in Keys the capital city
were utterly Resolute don't give them an
inch of our land yeah well I don't I
can't speak to that because I don't know
what the preconditions for peace might
be but I do know that naive Notions that
the Russians are going to lose somehow
or that we're going to win
I I don't I just don't understand I
don't understand that well what do you
mean we're going to win what are we
going to win here exactly well I guess a
victory would be that the Russians
retreated from Ukraine
with with Ukrainian ruins
right well that's a hell of a victory
like I think Putin could manage that
because I think he could tell his people
and I think they might buy it it's like
we accomplished our objective we
devastated Ukraine and we kept it out of
the hands of the West
we can't win against Vladimir Putin
anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to
period
and we can't say no to Putin because we
sold our soul for his oil and gas and we
did that to elevate our moral stature in
relationship to saving the planet and so
here we are yeah facing a very dire
winter
hoisted on the patard of our own
foolishness and moral presumption we're
saving the planet
we'll see I don't think so
and you could trade every political
analyst on CNN MSNBC etc etc for a
little of that right there